hi i'm christopher hines today we're
going to be talking about
how important weapon length is and we're
going to do it in kind of an interesting
way that i hope will be fun for
everybody
so you know the way we teach aikido and
talk about aikido it's about
making a harmonious interaction and then
if someone's coming towards us and we
can't make that harmonious interaction
how do we keep distance and keep
ourselves from getting caught
by the person attacking us i personally
believe that
it's highly important if someone's you
know you're in a life-threatening
situation and you're trying to get away
from someone and they're actively trying
to chase you down
that you should have something in your
hand to give you a little bit of a reach
priority right so
a little little bit of length um so what
we're going to do today is we're going
to test a few different length sized
weapons
with josh and maya and josh trying to
escape my trying to get him
and they're all going to be foam so
meaning that they won't actually hurt
at all and we're going to see if just
the length of the weapon
actually plays into josh being more
successful or not so
just the fact that there's a weapon so
maya won't be hurt by it and my
objective is just to get josh
and then once she gets him that's going
to be good right so
so our win criteria for maya is going to
be she gets her arms around josh in some
kind of way that we don't train for in
aikido right so
a katate or a kata or some kind of uh
inferior grab like we train for nike all
the time that won't count josh can still
work out of those but if she gets some
kind of bear hug or takes him down or
something
then josh loses that round right they're
going to go for a minute we're going to
see in a minute
how many times josh can get maya with
these weapons and josh is going to have
different length weapons to see how much
just the length of him moving something
contributes or doesn't contribute to it
going on so i'm going to call josh and
maya out here we're going to go to work
for you guys josh maya
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so let's talk a little bit
about what the aikido ma eye is
and why that ma i is important and how
weapons
change that ma eye so our basic ma and
iq
is this distance so that's our basic my
eye right there right
now at this distance neither one of us
could touch each other without taking a
step right so the longest thing i have
is my leg
i can't reach him with my leg without
taking a step right
now the reason that's important is
because if
i take a step it gives him enough
reaction time that he could probably
get out of the way or defend himself
right so meaning if he sees me take a
step he could take a counter step and
get out of the way of that right
now if i'm in really close on this guy i
can probably do something so
fast that he won't have reaction time to
it right so meaning for this close i
could just move my arm and hit him
that's very very little reaction time he
has to realize i'm hitting him and then
bring his arm up to hit me right
maybe move his body but he would have to
be able to move his body pretty fast
because i can move my hand real fast
or take a step and take the steps really
slow so at this range it's very likely
that i'm going to get him at least
once before he has some kind of reaction
to that okay
now if we go to say a long a long weapon
let's say to a really long weapon okay
so he's got this if he reaches out with
this we check on my eye so here's where
the my eye would be
with this long weapon all right now if
he just hold that down to your side for
a second okay now here's our old my eye
here's our old mai right here okay and
now our new eye
is here so this means before i can touch
josh josh can touch me right so meaning
look if i step in don't do anything if i
step in this close
i still can't reach josh i still can't
kick josh yet josh
can totally hit me right so josh can
totally get me
which means josh is going to get one
free shot
on me before i can break down the
distance to get a hold of him
right so that length is super super
important
now of course as the weapon gets smaller
that advantage gets smaller and smaller
as well
but at this with something like this
length so a sword which is maybe
something
back in the day that guys thought a lot
about having right that means that i
can't possibly get josh without taking
one more step and yet josh can get me so
if josh maintains his ma
i this i have to take two steps to get
josh
one i'm now in josh's danger zone still
can't get him still can't kick him two
and now finally i can get josh so i'm
going to give him
two beats of time in which he can hit me
and also
two beats of time which he can escape
from right
so if we're in our small my eye and i go
to get him he's just one steps all he
gets but with a longer weapon he gets
two steps so even if the weapon is not
um that dangerous to the other person
attacking it's still going to give you
more time and more attack potential
for them to cover that distance
[Music]
so
all right guys so um that was what it
looks like with three different weapons
so
understand that that weapon is foam all
three of those weapons were foam
so there is natural flinch reaction
right so you could see especially the
last one there
maya was really trying to protect her
head because it's no fun to have
something come across your eyes like
that or it pops you in the air that's no
fun
but that's a piece of foam she's not
scared of the foam she just doesn't want
it hitting her in a bad way
imagine if that was a lead pipe or a
sword right so
you you buy yourself so much more time
by having something of length
in your hand now you might say well for
practical self-defense
who cares about that the truth is that
should teach you that when you think
you're getting into a threatening
situation you should immediately looking
for something longer
to hit people with because even if it's
not a severe weapon it will
buy you time and buy you attack
potential and hopefully ideally buy you
some perception of more danger right so
meaning if they slow down more and
they're like oh i don't want to get hit
with that whatever pool cue you have
whatever weird thing you have
then that's good it buys you more time
which is what you want remember you're
just trying to make your escape
or buy time for help to arrive or
whatever series of things can happen
right so
you know either you're going to get to a
superior weapon platform where you could
decisively end the fight which
is not ideal but that's might what have
to happen you're going to
make an escape so you get away from that
person or other people are going to be
able to intervene and stop it from
happening right
so those those are different ways that
you're buying yourself time but that's
what you're looking for
and lengthen weapon definitely does that
and so that's why
we always do our drills with something
in your hand because
you should always be looking to have
something in your hand and understand
that a lot of the techniques in aikido
are only going to come out
when they have you have something in
your hand right so if you notice that
when maya was coming in for josh with
the sword it she there was way more
wrist grabbing going on because she just
couldn't get any closer than the wrist
right so she's trying to
cover that deadly zone as quick as
humanly possible and the wrist was what
was available to her so that's what
she's snagging to try and get a hold of
him and you can see why
for our context that being able to clear
your wrist is really important because
if they get a hold of my wrist that
means they can soon get a hold of my
body and i don't want that so
the second they get my wrist i have to
be able to successfully clear it
and that's what's going to enable me to
be free so i'm christopher
thanks a lot for watching take care